[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
lockern oder nicht lockern das ist die
frage während die omikron welle
hierzulande wie prognostiziert noch
immer höher wird nimmt sozusagen in
erwartung des baldigen scheitelpunkt die
diskussion über die abschaffung der anti
corinna maßnahmen fahrt auf schauen wir
uns die aktuellen zahlen an
1133 1000 173 neuinfektionen meldete das
lka heute die 7 tage inzidenz hier der
verlauf seit letzten november steigt
damit weiter auf den höchstwert von über
1400 die welle wächst noch während die
zahl der gemeldeten intensiv medizinisch
behandelten wo wird 19 fälle aber nicht
steigt sondern im gleichen zeitraum
sogar leicht sinkt auf aktuell
auch ein erfolg der korona maßnahmen
meint heute
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach den
mann nicht durch zu frühe lockerungen
gefährden dürfe wann ist der richtige
zeitpunkt dazu gleich unser
sonntagsgespräch zunächst der bericht
von peter wimmer
thomas voß haar ist chefarzt einer
lungenklinik in moers er hat in zwei
jahren corona alles gesehen was die
krankheit den menschen antun kann jetzt
sagt er sei der zeitpunkt gekommen die
pandemie auslaufen zu lassen
die variante omikron goethe wegen der
milderen krankheitsverläufen die chance
dazu und ermöglicht eine neue strategie
weil wir eine hohe und stabile
grundimmunisierung in der bevölkerung
haben vor allem in der wohngruppe über
60 da sind 88 prozent die impf
mindestens zweimal und die omikron
variante ist hochansteckend verbreitet
sich sehr schnell sie hat aber ein
geringes krank machendes potenzial das
heißt die krankheitslast aus omikron
heraus ist gering und deshalb ist das
genau der moment des übergangs von der
prämien dienten ende mai heißt das virus
wurde alljährlich auftauchen aber
beherrschbar seien mit symptomen wie
husten schnupfen heiserkeit wie bei der
grippe um aber eine starke grund
immunität aufzubauen müssen sich
möglichst viele menschen natürlich
infizieren jede natürliche infektion
führt zu einer breiteren um feindlichen
stabileren immunität als allein eine
impfung wobei die impfung nicht dass ich
falsch verstanden werde die grundlage
erst wenn man ist um so etwas zulassen
zu können das virus laufen lassen im
vorsichtigen deutschland das kommt zu
früh sagt etwa der chef der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft
trotz guter ausgangslage auf der
intensivstation ist die lage im moment
stabil dort haben wir im prinzip keine
steigerungsraten mehr und sehr leichte
absenkungen der zahn einen leichten
rückgang aber hier auch noch keine
endgültige entwarnung
es geht vor allem um die ungeimpften in
risikogruppen bei den über 60 jährigen
sind 88 3 prozent doppelt und 75,2
prozent dreifach geimpft doch es gibt
nach wie vor etwa drei millionen
ungeimpfte in dieser gruppe mit dem
größten intensiv risiko die impfkampagne
stagniert seit wochen wenn man da den
offiziellen zahlen glaubt dann sind das
immer noch drei millionen menschen über
60 dadurch dass sie hat relativ viele
menschen über 60 haben die nicht
geschützt sind die also bisher keine
impfung haben und auch keine infektion
durchgemacht haben und drei millionen
menschen jetzt einem risiko auszusetzen
ist einfach immer noch zu viel thomas
voß alles das nicht gelten er vermisst
eine strategie die bisher ungeimpften zu
erreichen dann einen exit punkt zu
setzen die gegenfrage ist auf welche
impfquote will man denn warten wo es
also das ziel man muss ja ein ziel
definieren wo sollen sie denn liegen
wenn wir jetzt schon 88 haben bei den
über 60 jährigen und wie will ich dann
dieses ziel eigentlich erreichen will
ich dann die letzten auch zur impfung
bewegen das ist eine entscheidende frage
sonst kann man dieses argument nicht
gelten lassen team vorsicht oder team
laufen lassen deutschland gespalten wie
hier in düsseldorf
wenn ich nicht in ordnung dass wir jetzt
schon lockern das ist meines erachtens
viel zu früh viele menschen sind noch
gar nicht geht also ich würde jetzt
nicht sagen ich will möchte unbedingt
dass das lockerer bord vielleicht ist so
auch davon abhängig zu welcher
generation angehört hatte ich schon viel
davon weil die lebensqualität ist sich
schon extremst einschränkt durch diese
ganzen maßnahmen ich finde es konsequent
und richtig zu der jetzigen zeit der
offensichtlich omikron nicht so
soweit sich verfestigt im körper als
dass man sagen kann das würde große
schäden nach sich ziehen
thomas voß h ist auch chef des verbands
der lungen kliniken und hat mit kollegen
aus verschiedenen disziplinen ein papier
veröffentlicht leben mit cupid wir
werden das virus nie wieder los sagt er
man muss sich mit ihm arrangieren
in seiner heimat rhede im münsterland
begrüße ich den nordrhein westfälischen
ministerpräsidenten
hendrik wüst hallo und gleich die erste
frage team vorsicht oder team laufen
lassen haben wir gerade gehört wo ordnen
sie sich ein
grüße sie frau schausten die
leichtere krankheitsverläufe bei omikron
geben uns die chance bald in eine neue
phase der pandemie einzutreten wir
sollten uns vorbereiten die
grundrechtseingriff für stück für stück
zurück zu nehmen wenn der scheitelpunkt
der höhepunkt dieser welle erreicht ist
und wir sehen dass das kranken das
gesundheitssystem das system in den
krankenhäusern sowohl auf den normales
oft auf den intensivstationen stabil ist
sie sprechen von bald was heißt dass die
nächste ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist
ja für den 16 2 geplant werden sie dort
einen konkreten fahrplan abstimmen
erarbeiten der den menschen dann auch
eine klare perspektive für das frühe
gibt
aktuell sehen wir ja immer noch
steigende zahlen 230 240.000
neuinfektionen am tag der höhepunkt ist
offensichtlich noch nicht erreicht karl
lauterbach der bundesgesundheitsminister
hat davon gesprochen dass wir in einem
best case im besten szenario
400.000 am tag infiziert haben werden
insofern laufen wir auf diesen höhepunkt
noch zu und ich glaube es ist richtig
bei der verabredung zu bleiben mitte des
monats am 16 bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundesregierung gemeinsam dann zu
verabreden was wir tun wenn das
gesundheitssystem stabil bleibt und wir
den höhepunkt überschritten haben nun
ist allerdings das meinungsspektrum
unter dem ministerpräsidenten jahr
extrem breit von schleswig-holstein
herrn günther der er den dänischen weg
gehen will also soviel öffnung wie
möglich bis zu winfried kretschmann in
baden-württemberg der ja doch er
wirklich auf die auf die bremse tritt
das lässt ja jetzt nicht wirklich eine
klare linie eine klare schnelle linie
erwarten für die nächsten monate wer es
nicht ihre aufgabe dafür zu sorgen als
vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
wir haben es in den letzten monaten ja
immer wieder gesehen dass die situation
vor ort auch sehr unterschiedlich sind
wir erinnern uns an über 1000 instanzen
schon vor einigen wochen in
süddeutschland und in norddeutschland
bei einer sehr überschaubare infektions
situation insofern kann man im detail
immer natürlich abweichen das muss man
sich auch gegenseitig zu gestehen aber
wenn wir jetzt die chance nutzen
irgendwann in eine andere phase
einzutreten und die einschränkung
zurückzunehmen dann ist es richtig dass
konsistent zu tun das klar zu tun und
das verabredet zu tun damit die menschen
auch verstehen was hier geschieht wenn
es jedes land wieder einzeln macht
glaube ich lösen die verwirrung aus und
das wäre nicht gut ja und sie sprechen
aber jetzt auch von irgendwann also
vielleicht können sie doch die
perspektive etwas konkretisieren reden
wir über märz oder reden wir über juni
alle experten sagen uns dass wir mitte
februar vielleicht auch ende februar
aber in diesem zeitraum den höhepunkt
dieser welle erreicht haben werden und
wir sollten uns darauf vorbereiten wir
sollten dann definieren welche schritte
wir gehen wenn wir sehen dass in diesem
moment das gesundheitssystem stabil ist
die kanten sein nicht überlastet sind
das vorzubereiten wird die aufgabe sein
vor der nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mitte
dieses monats und wenn wir dann die
situation die ich gerade beschrieben
habe erreicht haben dann ist es richtig
wenn wir dann auch in die öffnungen
gehen wenn wir dann konkret auch vorher
definiert haben was machen wir dann alle
gemeinsam braucht es nach ihrer meinung
noch einen impfpflicht der neue cdu chef
friedrich merz hat man einen plan für
eine gestaffelte impfpflicht vorgelegt
die nur bei einer neuen welle greifen
soll so kann man es verstehen und alters
abstufung beinhaltet sie waren ja
zuletzt jedenfalls für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht
haben da ja auch versucht den
bundeskanzler unter druck zu setzen
davon sind sie nun auch abgekommen wir
könnten heute viel ambitionierter über
öffnungen sprechen wenn mehr menschen
geimpft wäre wir haben leider impflücken
in deutschland auch im bereich der 50 60
jährigen und darüber die beim falle
einer infektion auch mit omikron dann
ins krankenhaus müssen zu einer größeren
zahl als jedenfalls junge menschen
deswegen ist es wichtig dass sich mehr
menschen impfen lassen dass wir da dran
bleiben an dem thema und nach meiner
überzeugung wird es ohne eine
impfpflicht nicht gehen es liegen viele
verschiedene ideen auf dem tisch in
eckpunkte papieren die man jetzt sieht
ich finde es bemerkenswert dass die
regierung keinen gemeinsamen vorstoß
macht findet aller ehren wert dass für
sich mehr als jetzt den vorstoß macht
dass mindestens die größte
oppositionsfraktion eine gemeinsame
linie findet wenn schon chaos ist in der
regierung dann sollte wenigstens die
opposition eine abgestimmte meinung habe
ich unterstütze das das heißt dann sind
sie da auch eingeschränkt und
unterstützen jetzt den märz vorschlag so
verstehe ich sie vielleicht dann noch
die prognose glauben sie am ende das wir
im mai eine impfpflicht tatsächlich
haben ich unterstütze in jedem fall die
einführung einer impfpflicht es sind
sehr sehr viele fragen offen um so
wichtiger wäre es gewesen frühzeitig
einen gesetzentwurf vorzulegen auch die
bundestagsfraktion hat viele fragen
gestellt und sie vor der von der
bundesregierung nicht beantwortet
bekommen deswegen wird es zeit dass wir
auch gerne gemeinsam ich habe das
angebot an die bundesregierung gemacht
für die unions-geführten
gemeinsam darüber sprechen wie wir zügig
eine impfpflicht
einführen weil ich glaube dass wir sie
brauchen werden sagt der
nordrhein-westfälische ministerpräsident
hendrik wüst danke nachrede danke ihnen
das gespräch haben wir aus termingründen
am späten nachmittag aufgezeichnet und
bleiben noch beim thema corona omikron
führt zwar in der regel zu leichteren
krankheitsverläufen aber zu spaßen ist
auch mit dieser variante nicht es gibt
viele impft durchbrüche und gerade
menschen mit vorerkrankungen fürchten
sich vor den folgen einer infektion
damit kommt antico mit medikamenten
immer mehr bedeutung zu auch für die
zukunft wenn die pandemie überwunden ist
corona aber in der welt bleibt petra
otto zeigt den aktuellen stand der
entwicklung
heiko bias ist schwer lungenkrank und er
ist corona infiziert trotz impfung
bekommt er atemnot und fiebere er geht
in die klinik denn auch bei der omicron
variante keine schwere verläufe geben
nachdem sich das abgezeichnet hat also
sind die richtung geht habe ich
natürlich geschockt und von dem habe ich
dann ganz wurde das ist ja mein freier
märkte problemlos passiert nix ist wird
besser und ich gehe mal davon aus dass
ist an den den substanzen liegt aber ich
bin dankbar die substanz die er bekam
ist erst seit einigen tagen verfügbar
der monoklonale antikörper so trophy mab
der speziell bei omikron gut wirkt eine
einzige infusion genügt wichtigster
aspekt ist aus meiner sicht dass man das
natürlich macht wenn die infektion
frisch ist was wir hoffen ist dass wir
bei hochrisikopatienten schwere verläufe
vermeiden schwere verläufe heiß zum
beispiel intensiv und badens
flüchtigkeit corona medikamente die gab
es lange gar nicht dann mussten sie erst
ausprobieren was wann wem hilft jetzt
ist einiges im einsatz und sie warten
auf die neu zugelassenen antiviren
tabletten auf pak suite das pack slowik
von dem erhoffen wir auch das ist
vielleicht antikörper gaben nicht
notwendig macht also statt infusion
tabletten viel einfacher zu handhaben
das virus sei es verändert sich zurzeit
viele fälle aber nur wenige schwere in
den kliniken kehrt zur etwas wie routine
ein wir erfahren zunimmt mehr welche
medikamente wer in welchem stadium wir
einsetzen der ton jeden tag neu dazu
lernen wir sind auf einem guten weg
meine hoffnung ist dass er natürlich
irgendwann so gute medikamente haben
dass zu jedem gehalt bekommen corona
behandlung könnte vor allem sache der
hausärzte werden markus babbel hat seit
fast zwei jahren eine corona
schwerpunktpraxis alles umstrukturiert
auch er kann diese ganz neuen antikörper
infusion verabreichen das mussten sie
erst üben an puppen in schutzkleidung
sind war wirklich andere leistungsgrenze
in vielen bereichen und uns zukünftig
noch mehr wird dann muss man gucken das
aus gestemmt kriegen aber er fühlt sich
zuständig als hausarzt gerade jetzt da
neue medikamente zur verfügung stehen
die auch neben und wechselwirkungen
haben wir kennen die patienten mit ihrer
vorgeschichte wir können irgendwie als
risiko viel viel besser abschätzen ob
wir medikamente einsetzen müssen oder ob
die leichte infekte einfassung abklingt
corona heilen das sieht markus biebl
erstmal nicht aber er kann an corona
erkrankte zunehmend besser behandelt
und nun zunächst nachrichten mit gundula
gause
verteidigungsministerin lambrecht hat
den weiteren einsatz der bundeswehr im
westafrikanischen mali in frage gestellt
sie haben nicht den eindruck sagte sie
in der zdf sendung berlin direkt dass
man dort länger willkommen sei schon
aussenministerin baerbock hatte zweifel
an dem einsatz in mali geäußert die
bundeswehr hat dort rund 1400 soldaten
und soldatinnen als teil von eu und un
missionen stationiert zuvor hatte
ministerin lambrecht der funke
mediengruppe gegenüber eine bereitschaft
zur entsendung weiterer
bundeswehrsoldaten
litauen erklärt deutschland führt dort
den nato einsatz an dem rund 600
bundeswehrangehörige beteiligt sind
diese pläne unterstützte auch
bundeskanzler scholz in der ard scholz
und lambrecht bekräftigten ihr nein zu
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
indessen treffen die von den usa
angekündigten truppenverstärkungen in
europa ein soldaten einer elite division
landeten in polen im südosten nahe der
grenze zur ukraine
etwa 1700 us-soldaten sollen dorthin
verlegt werden zugleich hat russland
weitere soldaten nach belarus gebracht
mittlerweile sind es nach westlichen
angaben mehr als
100.000 mann mit schwerem gerät an den
grenzen zur ukraine
olaf scholz ist in der luft richtung
amerika 60 tage nach amtsantritt startet
der bundeskanzler us-präsident beiden
seinen antrittsbesuch ab und muss dabei
auch zweifel ausräumen wo deutschland im
konflikt russland ukraine steht
unbegründete zweifel meinte scholz vor
ein paar tagen hier im heute-journal und
wiederholte seine position nun nochmals
im ard-interview stopp von nord stream 2
alles liegt auf dem tisch
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine wir
haben es gehört nein und dabei soll es
bleiben zu den erwartungen an scholz
termin im weißen haus aus washington
benjamin daniel
der gegenwind ist nicht zu überhören in
diesen tagen olaf scholz macht sich auf
gen washington sein antritt besuch
überschattet von der ukraine krise dem
kanzler geht es um zwei zentrale punkte
erstens wie machen wir klar dass eine
militärische aggression gegen die
ukraine hohe kosten für russland hätte
das ist von uns immer betont worden und
darüber haben wir sehr genaue absprachen
vorbereitet mit den usa mit der
europäischen union und allen die es
angeht und die zweite klare teil der
zweite klare teil unserer strategie ist
dafür zu sorgen dass
wieder gesprochen wird
[Applaus]
unter freunden können wir ruhig ein
wenig informeller seien schöne alte welt
obama kennen die reagan in berlin diese
so oft gezeigten archivbilder stehen für
ein deutsch amerikanisches verhältnis
wie es früher wahrgenommen wurde freunde
tief verbunden natürlich nicht ohne
streitpunkte aber grundsätzlich doch auf
derselben seite
nicht wenige zweifeln daran dass das
auch heute noch selbstverständlich ist
die präsidentschaft trumps hat das
verhältnis der usa zu ihren verbündeten
beschädigt lügen aggressionen ab france
einstige gewissheiten erschüttert was
hier in washington häufig nicht wirklich
ausreichend wahrgenommen wird ist die
tatsache dass der reputationsverlust und
der vertrauensverlust der vereinigten
staaten ungeheuer stark ist und
natürlich durch den unglücklichen und
schlecht organisierten abzug aus
afghanistan noch einmal verstärkt wurde
das ist etwas was olaf scholz hier auch
klar kommunizieren muss jetzt hat also
nicht nur das weiße haus einen neuen
chef sondern auch das kanzleramt und
amerika scheint nicht so ganz sicher zu
sein was es vom neuen in berlin halten
soll
das liegt auch am verhaltenen verhalten
der bundesregierung gegenüber china aber
vor allem irritiert das zögerliche
agieren berlins in der ukraine krise
während die usa truppen entsenden und
waffen liefern bietet deutschland bisher
5000 helmer
hier in den usa sind wir ökonomisch und
auch in anderer weise geschützt vor den
unmittelbaren implikationen eines
solchen waffengang ist insofern ist es
auch hier wichtig dafür zu werben dass
die situation in europa eine andere ist
und auf verständnis hoffen was aber auch
im umkehrschluss gilt und bedeutet dass
deutschland seiner größeren
verantwortung gerecht werden muss und
das heißt sozusagen übersetzt auch mit
ganz klaren positionen unter umständen
auch was waffenlieferungen defensive
waffenlieferungen die ukraine an
und dann gibt es ja noch die dauer
differenz zwischen den usa und
deutschland mögliche sanktionen gegen
die nord stream pipeline
der präsident hat der deutschen
bundesregierungen einen vorschuss
gegeben er hat viel politisches kapital
hier im land verbraucht das direkte
sanktionen gegen deutschland behindert
worden das heißt es muss hier zu einer
einigung kommen das wird auch bedeuten
dass deutschland auf die usa zu gehen
muss und so blickt washington
erwartungsvoll darauf wie groß die
schritte sein werden mit den in
deutschland in diesen fragen auf seinen
größten partner zugehen wird
wir werden morgen darüber berichten zum
70 jährigen thronjubiläum wählte die
queen himmelblau seit sieben jahrzehnten
ist ihre garderobe immer auch botschaft
und so verlieh die gewählte farbe der
95-jährigen frische und tatkraft das
passte zu ihrem erneuerten versprechen
nicht vor ende ihres lebens abzudanken
länger als jeder andere britische
monarch oder monarchen sitzt elisabeth
dietz weiter auf dem thron und hat
vielen stürmen getrotzt denen der welt
läuft und denen die ihr die eigene
familie bescherte aus london andreas
stand
immer im dienst unermüdlich
unverwüstlich die queen fast 96 vor ihr
der rote koffer mit den
regierungsdokumenten noch philips tod
nach fast 75 jahren ehe und
gesundheitlichen problemen will die
königin zeigen sie erfülle weiter ihre
pflicht wie sie es als junger frauen
bevor sie den thron bestieg versprochen
hatte
ich erkläre vor ihnen allen dass mein
ganzes leben marke lang oder kurz seien
in ihren diensten stehen soll
im statement zum siebzigsten
thronjubiläum erneuert die queen dieses
versprechen abdankung also
ausgeschlossen dazu ein geschenk für
charles wenn ihr sohn könig wird darf
seine frau sich queen carmela nennen was
lange umstritten war gilt camilla doch
als mitverantwortlich für das scheitern
von charles erster her mit dana am
vorabend des thronjubiläums empfing die
queen gäste in ihrer residenz sendung
humor wie immer trocken die widmung auf
der torte falsch rum so der hinweis
damit die presse sie lesen können
elisabeth kommentar ich zähle hier nicht
sie hatte dieses funkeln in den augen
dann ihr sinn für humor sie wirkte fit
ein wenig fragil war sie aber welch
wunderbare humor der ist wirklich
herausragend
umgeben von ersten geschenken kleine
symbole dafür dass die queen die
relevanz der monarchie erhalten konnte
durch sieben jahrzehnte voller
veränderungen als ein die nation einen
des band
stabilität sie ist ein anker der
stabilität in zeiten von krieg und
frieden gesellschaftlicher ruhe und
aufruhr und jüngst in der pandemie
pandemic der heutige tag bleibe so
elisabeth auch an diesem jubiläum einer
der trauer um ihren vater könig georg
den sechsten auch deshalb und in der
hoffnung auf gutes wetter mit mit der
großen feier bis juni gewartet
da wird sie dann noch mal richtig
gefeiert und ein hoch auf alle alten
damit dieser generation so jetzt nochmal
nachrichten müller zunächst mit
fußballergebnissen zum abschluss des 21
spieltages gewann der vfl wolfsburg klar
gegen den tabellenletzten greuther fürth
4 zu 1 wolfsburg verbesserte sich damit
auf platz 12 der tabelle
viele tore kassierte auch borussia
dortmund der tabellenzweite unterlag dem
tabellendritten bayer leverkusen 25
die bahnstrecke zwischen berlin und
hamburg ist voraussichtlich bis mittwoch
gesperrt ein brennender kabelschacht bei
wittenberge in brandenburg hat die
sicherheitsanlage lahmgelegt laut
polizei eine technische störung die bahn
bietet ersatzverkehr mit bussen und
regionallinien an im siegerland ist eine
talbrücke an der a 45 erfolgreich
gesprengt worden planmäßig fiel die
marode brücke rinsdorf in sich zusammen
mit mehr als 70 metern höhe war sie die
bisher höchste brücke die in deutschland
gesprengt wurde die bereits errichtete
neue brücke direkt daneben wurde nicht
beschädigt insgesamt müssen auf der
sauerlandlinie 60 brücken saniert werden
zum sonntagabend gehört die frage was
hält die nächste woche für uns bereit
die diplomatische offensive zum russland
ukraine konflikt geht nach dem
usa-besuch von kanzler scholz direkt
weiter damit beginnt der ausblick von
simone friedrich
[Musik]
bundeskanzler scholz hat für dienstag zu
einem ukraine gipfel nach berlin geladen
er will mit frankreichs präsident marco
und dem polnischen präsidenten du da die
lage besprechen und das gemeinsame
vorgehen in der ukraine krise abstimmen
am donnerstag wird die berlinale
eröffnet eins der größten film festivals
der welt trotz corona eine
präsenzveranstaltung
allerdings mit strengen regeln nach
angaben der festivalleitung ist das eng
mit den gesundheitsbehörden abgestimmten
es sei wichtig kultur weiter zu
ermöglichen
wer als neue bundespräsidentin schloss
bellevue einzieht wird am sonntag
entschieden voraussichtlich kann
amtsinhaber steinmeier eine zweite
amtszeit antreten er hat die
unterstützung von spd grünen und union
außerdem stehen der von der linkspartei
aufgestellte sozialmediziner trabert und
der von der afg nominierte ökonom otte
zur wahl
und das wetter wird sich nach diesem
stürmischen sonntag in der kommenden
woche beruhigen der deutsche
wetterdienst warnt allerdings für die
nacht noch vor orkanböen in höheren
lagen süddeutschlands
morgen wird es noch stürmisch und
wechselhaft sonne gibt es nur im norden
und im südwesten sonst viele schauer und
schnee an den alpen bei 1 bis 9 grad ab
dienstag lässt der wind allmählich nach
im norden noch regen im süden öfter
sonne es wird noch milder am donnerstag
6 bis 13 grad
so viel von uns beiden morgen an dieser
stelle marietta slomka und heinz wolf
nachrichten gibt's hier später um 0.30
und immer aktuell in unserer zdf heute
[Musik]